some people say you have to be broken to
be fixed again
my name is asha phillip
[Music]
and i run athletics for me
was just a bit of fun it was something
different and it was something new
trampolining was my main sport and i
loved it
and then i fell into a double mini
trampolining and then i became a
junior champion here i was at the world
championships in quebec
i bounced up but when i came down
i didn't land right i could just hear
the crunch
i could just see my leg pointing in a
different direction
and i just remember grabbing my leg and
then just screaming and screaming
there was nothing cold in my legs to
give her
in a heartbeat everything was just gone
anything i worked hard for had vanished
everyone told me i was a write-off so
how does a child
of age of 17 get back up
it felt like i'd lost something i lost a
part of me i wanted to give up
and when you're at the point of just
giving up that's when you meant to
really turn your life around and change
it was my mom who believed in me and for
that i believed in her
i really do question how i made it out
it was little by little
coming in to do the rehab step by step
you started to see improvement
the couches went away then i could walk
i was able to jog and then
run but then i had loads of injuries
along the way
the only thing standing between success
and failure
is mental toughness it's about being
resilient
being an athlete isn't like a normal job
the gym
strengthening the were the fitness
for one shot for 11 seconds
there are a lot of knockbacks a lot it's
how you handle it
but it's also the most amazing release i
let all my stresses
all my bad energy every time i shop to
train
i have the opportunity to learn more
about myself and how to run correctly
some people train brilliantly but in a
race
they don't win you need focus
you're in an arena of thousands of
people then you're on the start line
there's seven other women then you have
a man holding a gun and you have to
learn to channel all this not panic
but there's so much going on with your
family in the crowd everyone's screaming
wanting you to do well obviously they're
screaming for the girls alongside you
how'd you put it all aside and say okay
i have to focus on myself
focus on my lane focus on me
there are sacrifices there are lots of
ways to have fun
go after your goals and balance it out
the right way
in the end it's about knowing what's
important to you and what makes you
thrive
that's not just athletics that's life